rare close-up video of a Sumatran tiger
and two Cubs was captured recently in a
camera trap in the jungle of Indonesia's
Sumatra island the World Wildlife Fund
set up the cameras to help monitor the
population of the Tigers in their
primary breeding grounds which the World
Wildlife Fund says is under threat from
poaching and deforestation the Tigers
approached the camera sniffed it and
then walked away the noise you hear is
one of the Tigers off camera inspecting
the apparatus the World Wildlife Fund
says the footage is a cause for
celebration the group says it's the
first time they've recorded evidence of
tiger breeding in central Sumatra there
are as few as 400 Sumatran tigers left
in Indonesia the World Wildlife Fund
says the tiger habitat is threatened by
companies clearing the forest for paper
and palm oil production as well as
illegal logging the infrared triggered
camera traps are activated when they
since body heat in their path these
cameras are placed nearly a month ago
along a wildlife corridor known to be
used by Tigers after five years of the
World Wildlife Fund study in sumatra
using wildlife activated still camera
traps these are the first images of a
tiger with offspring